من الملف السوداني حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره
باسقاط طائره عسكريه للجيش السوداني في
مدينه ام درمان غرب الخرطوم هذا وقال مصدر
بقوات الدعم السريع للجزيره انها اثرت
طيارا كان على متن المقاتله بعد اسقاطها
وتداولا ينشطون صورا لاشتعال الطائره
بالنيران بعد اصابتها وهبوط الطيارين او
الطيارين الذين كان على متنها بالمظلات
هذا واكد مصدر عسكري بالجيش السوداني
للجزيره استعادته مطابع العمله في العاصمه
الخرطوم من سيطره من وصفهم بالمتمردين
وكان مسؤول الرفيع بالجيش اكد في وقت سابق
ان من وصفها بالمليشيات المتمرده قد هاجمت
مطابع العمله مستهدفه نهب الاموال
واحتياطيات السودان من الذهب فالاثناء
رصده مراسل الجزيره اطلاق نار متقطع
بالاسلحه الثقيله لقوات الدعم السريع في
منطقه جنوب غرب الخرطوم ردا على تحليق
للطيران الحربي التابع للجيش في المنطقه
قال مصدر بالجيش السوداني للجزيره انما
اسماها الميليشيا المتمرده استهدفت
القاعده الجويه في وادي سيدنا بمدافع
الكاتيوشا والهون واسلحه الدفاع الجوي فجر
اليوم الثاني لوقف اطلاق النار واضاف
المصدر ان الجيش تعامل مع المهاجمين دون
ذكرى نتيجه هذه الاشتباكات
من جنوب الخرطوم معنا مراسع الجزيره
الطاهر المرضي ضعنا في صوره الاوضاع
الطاهر المرضي وسطى حديثا عن اسقاط طائره
للجيش السوداني من قبل قوات الدرع السريعه
نعم يمكنني القول ان الان هي اجواء حرب
على الرغم من هذه الهدنه المعلنه والتي
بدات متماسكه في اليوم الاول والثاني ولكن
اليوم هي اجواء حرب حيث يندلع القتال في
عدد من المناطق سواء كان في ام درمان او
بالقرطوم جنوب او في شرق النيل ونشاهد
اعمده الدخان تتصاعد في اماكن مختلفه
ونسمع الدويه الانفجارات وكذلك
الرصاصه واضح ان هذه الهدنه الان هي هدنه
غير متماسكه اندلع القتال وتبادل الطرفان
الاتهامات خاصه وان الجيش السوداني اتهم
قوات الدعم السريع بانها انتهكت هذه
الهدنه وقامت بالاستيلاء
صك العمله باني صكه العمله ثم تحدث لاحقا
انه استعاد هذه المنطقه وكذلك قال الدعم
السريع انه اسقط طائره فوق سماء مدينه ام
درمان واعتبر ذلك خرقا ايضا للهدنه نحن
نتحدث عن هدنه الان يمكنني القول بان هذه
الهدنه في هذه اللحظات انهارت تماما وان
الاشتباكات في مواقع متعدده والاتهامات
يعني متبادله بين الطرفين هذه الهدنه
الوحيده التي كان
المواطنين او كان البعض يرى انها ستكون
هدنه باعتبارنا متميزه عن بقيه الهدن
السابقه باعتبار ان فيها لجنه مراقبه
مكونه من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والسعوديه وممثلين للطرفين الجيش السوداني
وقوات دعم سريعه اعتقد ان لجنه المراقبه
المكونه هذه هو خاصه الوسطاء الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والسعوديه امام تحدي
كبير واختبار صعب في كيفيه اعاده هذه
الهدنه الى الى وضعها الذي يعني تم
الالتزام به على الرغم من ان الطرفين قد
الالتزما بهذه الهدنه يواجهون ايضا تحديات
كبيره في كون ان تعود الهدنه هذه الى
مزهرها الطبيعي وان تكون هنالك التزامات
تحقق
او توقف هذا القتال الذي كان يامل
الكثيرون ان تكون هذه الهدنه هي بدايه
لوقف اطلاق نار دائم ولكن يبدو ان الظروف
الان مختلفه تماما في ميوزي هذه الظروف
وان ذلك سينعكس على الاوضاع الانسانيه
بالتاكيد خاصه وان هذه الهدنه تحديدا هي
تم الاتفاق ان تكون يعني لصالح الاوضاع
الانسانيه وفتح المسارات ومساعده
المواطنين وتهيئه المستشفيات التي كانت قد
توقفت بسبب تلك الاشتباكات واذاعه
النقاط الارتكازات للمواطنين لكي يتحركوا
بسهوله كل هذه الظروف الان اصبحت غير
مواتيه اللي ما تم الاتفاق عليه اشكرك
طاهر مرضي مراسي الجزيره